Sup playa? This week we in living
color with The Giver by Lois Lowry.
11-year old thug Jonas comin’ up in
a trap dat at first seem pretty legit. Unlike
the crooked outside world, or “elsewhere,”
this hood ain’t got no war, disease, hunger,
or poverty.
Truth is, though, the only reason
peeps keepin’ it so chill is cuz errybody
sippin on the philosophy of “sameness,”
which basically mean two things: errybody
livin like a bunch of lame-ass drones to keep
sh** peaceful, and a crew of old geezers callin
all the shots: who hooks up with who, how
many babies a biddy can pop out. Sh** they
even makin you pop pillz dat kill a brutha’s
mojo. Ugh. And when you too old to hack it
anymo, you get “released.” We’ll get
to dat later.
Now dat Jonas’s finally old enough
to count the hairs on his nuts, dem old folk
give him the special job of “Receiver of
Memories,” cuz unlike errybody else in the
streets, Jonas got “The Capacity to See
Beyond.” See back when the hood decided
to start preachin dat “sameness” jive,
dem old timers took all the world’s memories
and dumped em in the mind of just one G: the
“Reciever.”
And now the old reciever gonna get
up on his givin grind and pour da memories
outta his dome in to Jonas’s.
As da Giver packin dem memories in
to Jonas’s backside, Jonas be learnin about
all sorts of crazy sh*t he ain’t never known
about- the sun, snow, love, and even war.
By the time that Jonas gets a
little taste of what the Giver dealin, J-Dog
realize that the memories of the world filled
with too much pain, and not even the hardest
hustla can handle em solo without ODing. Jonas
asks The Giver “why cant we all share this
pain, yo? Lighten the load, naw mean?” If
we cut it up and share it with all the hood,
we can get this sh*t on lock. But the Giver
like ain’t happenin yo. Regular homies don’t
want pain. They just wanna keep things as
chill as possible. But Jonas ain’t buyin
dat mess.
Then one day Jonas learn that
gettin “released” is really just gettin
wasted by the man, and his little baby-buddy
Gabriel is next on the hit list. So he say
“Man f*** this. I’m out.”
Since memories last forever, Jonas gonna get
what he really wants: Cuz once he peaces outta
town, erryone’s gonna have to take a hit
of dem painful memories. Even though he want
The Giver to come, the G-man like “Nah burh.
I gotta hold it down and make sure nobody
loses their sh*t when they experience pain
and loneliness for the first time.”
So Jonas grabs baby Gabe and rolls
out to the outside world where things be all
sorts of nasty! But he gotta nut up and beast
through it all to keep him and Gabe alive.
When the book ends, Jonas and Gabe
cruisin on a sled towards some bright lights
in a window. And that’s it. Da hell?
First thing you gotz to know is that when
the author was a lil’ thug-ette she was
kickin it w peeps crazy bout keepin errybody
in line. A lotta scholars think it made old
Lo-Lo wanna spit some raw truth bout what
it’s like livin in a spot where somebody
ridin yo nuts 24/7.
Having somebody bust yo ass til it's
raw is gonna do you just like Jonas’s boy
Asher got did when he wasn’t talkin right.
In a world where the law gets all
up in your shit erry time you bone- up,
sometimes better to just throw up the deuce
to all dem haters.
But at the beginning of the book, Lowry makin
it seem like Jonas’s hood is the place to be.
Fo example, it seem like Jonas’s
daddy is a super righteous dude since he got
an ideal family and all he do is take care of
babies all day. Fool’s job title is even "Nurturer"
But on the real, there be some shady sh**
goin down under the
surface. When the Giver show Jonas a video
of his daddy on the grind, he realize that
pops ain’t just about nursin’ babies,
he also kills the ones that ain’t up to snuff.
Uh- uhh!
When Jonas realize how backwards things in
his hood be, he try to
use dem memories to open up erryone else’s
eyes, but ain’t none of his homies can feel
him on dat. Like my boy Ivan said in Solzhenitsyn’s
“One Day in the Life of Ivan Denisovich”-
“How can you expect a man who’s warm to
understand a man who’s cold?”
So in a way, Jonas just like dat
biblical gangsta Jonah, who was sent by the
big G-man to tell the crooked cats of Nineveh
that they best change their ways. And likewise,
Jonas gotta spread dat pain and feeling even
though them duds in the hood don’t want him to.
Look, homies always sayin ignorance is bliss, but is it?
Well the truth hurts, that's fo damn sure. But on
the real, a playa can’t experience life
without experiencin pain. Naw mean?
And on the same note, how you gonna know life
without subscribing, man?
Catch me next time playa. Peace.